es ist portugiesisch oder sogar elmo
warum ist man minecraft portugiesisch
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video einen euro von der
jump league welcher modus sonst in
deutschland die stammt wieder mal von
twitter von dave cave und zwar schreibt
er super secret settings challenge immer
wenn du unter fällst einmal umstellen
also immer wenn ich unter falle hier
einmal auf die super sieg mit settings
gehen und ich glaube das wird jetzt
meine schlechteste runde etwa weil super
secret settings einfach teilweise
richtig eklig sind also es kann
passieren dass das bild im kopf über ist
oder schwarzweiß verrauscht das gewiss
keine ahnung fische drin ab oder so ich
weiß nicht ob so was gibt aber würde
mich nicht wundern zu passiv settings
sind im allgemeinen nicht dafür gedacht
damit irgendwas zu spielen irgendwie
produktiv zu sein
aber ja die challenge hat euch gut
gefallen er hat irgendwie 12 august
bekommen die meisten fans auf alle
vorgeschlagenen challenges deswegen
denke ich mir okay wirklich kein
spielverderber sein
und wir spielen jetzt die challenge wie
gesagt jedes mal wenn ich runter fallen
werden einmal die super secret settings
geändert das heißt ich prophezeie jetzt
einfach mal so bald ich einmal
runtergefallen bin ist die runde vorbei
also das klingt jetzt bisschen
übertrieben aber gut andererseits weiß
man nicht welche super-sieg settings
jetzt dran kommen schön das wort super
sieg und settings sss 23 18 ich liebe es
ein erstes einfach nicht genug
3 s erstes gehalt bubble charts brauch
ich okay ganz ehrlich wenn ich jetzt die
runde mit 0 jump feld spielen würde wäre
natürlich auch geil würde müsste ich
kein einziges mal die settings ändern
aber leute lasst uns realistisch bleiben
das wird nicht passieren
ich hab da habe ich noch nie drohne mit
0 dumpings gespielt und das wird jetzt
auch heute wahrscheinlich keine
mitschuld am face kann natürlich seien
aber realistisch gesehen ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit relativ geringen
deswegen dürft ihr euch darauf
einstellen dass gleich mal richtig
eklige lustige schräge stick mit
settings reinkommen tut es aber auch
nicht gesagt dass man damit nicht
spielen kann
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist ich
habe selbst lange lange lange die
settings nicht mehr an gehabt die super
league wird und deswegen weiß ich gar
nicht was da kommt manche von euch die
vielleicht den ganzen tag super sieg
mitspielen
wir wissen jetzt können sich vorstelle
was kommt wobei ich auch glaube das ist
reine minister aber die andern zumindest
schon eine idee und so das ist
vielleicht der erste kritische sprung
da habe ich immer den arsch gerettet
diese kleinen treppenstufe oder unten
beziehungsweise sie hat mir meinen arsch
gerettet
ja läuft soweit gut aber wir sind beim
modul 5 ne bisher jump fehlerfrei ich
spiel jetzt heute natürlich ein bisschen
vorsichtiger weil ich natürlich trotzdem
eine möglichst gute runde spielen möchte
okay das geht auch brawn ein
an dieser stelle und es geht los aus der
faxe tier auch das was ich sehe mein
kopf ist gerade schwarz geworden
hallo hallo minecraft minecraft neu
gestartet kloster steht also abgesehen
davon dass mein handy athen chur was da
steht
motta und sogar d'or dallas sogar doris
private mama kann mit meinem spanisch
kann mir das erschließen
nadal ist der spieler im kader wäre dann
ein spieler der eos huber doris
portugiesisch oder sogar elmo warum ist
mein kopf ist portugiesisch
warum ok ich versuche meine reinzukommen
leute so leute zweite runde startet ich
laufe jetzt mal vor bis modul 5 da waren
wir glaube ich gerade eben so wir sind
jetzt beim sechs module angekommen dass
fünfter mehr abgeschlossen und jetzt
gilt wieder die gute alte challenge und
ich hoffe dass man sparen mein spanisch
dass man minecraft sich jetzt nicht
schon wieder auf irgend eine komische
sprache umstellt wenn ich sie gleich
runter falle wäre nicht so geil so wie
kommt man da noch mal hin
so jetzt kann man da aber so hin
ja und dann hier hat er noch eine der
fail intensivsten normen module
überhaupt eines der intensivsten module
gut so ja und jetzt muss wird darunter
sag ich
ja so trittin und da ist er ist fällt
alles klar ist dass man weiß warum ist
es portugiesisch
aber es zu bissig settings ist immer
noch normal okay und es wird wieder
schwarz aber nichts passiert okay leute
letzter versuch ich habe jetzt mal die
version gewechselt werden von minecraft
1.8 punkt 7 auf minecraft 1.8 runter
sind jetzt wieder am ende des fünften
moduls das hier ist unsere club momentan
und irgendwie scheinen die super six bei
mir nicht funktionieren warum auch immer
auf jeden fall läuft die challenge immer
noch und ich hoffe dass jetzt
funktionieren der 1.8 ich habe also
quasi ein downgrade in der version
gemacht und jetzt muss es irgendwie
laufen würde ich sagen wenn es jetzt
nicht läuft aber wir probieren aus gehen
davon aus dass es laufen wird
oder wir spielen da 100 einfach ohne
feld zu ende das wäre auch eine
möglichkeit
gut dann gucken wir mal sieht dass sie
zu weit alles ganz entspannt aus hier
eigentlich also dass jetzt keine große
challenge würde ich mal sagen ja das
kriegen wir hin
okay das ist modul da hätte ich auch
gerne mal immer öfter und zwar an der
stelle hier
diese sprung der bereitet mir das mal
kopfschmerz sind da ist der sfl jetzt
wird sich zeigen
man hofft immer noch auf portugiesisch
ob die super sandwich allerdings
funktionieren da kam geräusch
sechseinhalb stunden später was machen
wir jetzt ein bisschen was wir machen
ich sage einfach alle zwei kills alle
zwei kills ziehe ich ein rüstungsteile
aus im deathmatch so und ich würde sagen
wo führt das hin
es wird einfach dahin dass ich weil ich
ja ab und zu auch mal zweistellig kills
macht dann einfach am ende gar kein okay
erster kill gar keine rüstung ab okay
das ist ganz logisch schließlich keine
ahnung online
ja komm auf mich durch taliban am ende
noch besiegt bei meinem nächsten kill
ziehe ich eine rüstung style aus
natürlich zuerst mal die schuhe und ich
habe ich doch gesehen dass du wolltest
baby-schumi long beach gibt sehr schön
okay die ersten zwei sind geschafft und
ich ziehe meine bodies de pierro
ausmachen boots und versucht jetzt mit
einer combo beizukommen
ich treffe heute eine ganz gut aber ich
weiß noch nicht wirklich wichtig salata
ist er direkt wieder mit mary jane mit
neuen verwundbarkeit
ich weiß noch nicht wirklich wie ich die
combos dann auch halten soll so auf mein
nächstes werde ich auf jeden fall wissen
style ausziehen müssen
vielleicht wo ich mal den hier so kommt
ja ok dauern und wir müssen ein weiteres
rüstungsteile ausziehen ich sag den halo
werden uns auf jeden fall der nacktheit
man hat die ganze dieses tiefs über sich
gespannt merkte dass das ist mir das
neue plugin dann boxen sich jetzt die
boxen sexy boxen sich gute chance um
abzustauben
nein ist okay dann hole ich auch erstmal
alles die rohmasse kiste heraus habe ich
zumindest noch einen gegner
die pfeile darf ich mitnehmen so das
nehme ich mit meinem fall ist auch eine
gute sache jetzt geht es gegen den oder
hindernisse und es weg alles klar das
ging schnell vergessen zu haus zu ziehen
kann sein okay wisst ihr was ich mache
mache die hardcore challenge der kämpfe
einfach zur strafe gegen dafür jetzt
gegen ihn einfach komplett ohne rüstung
einfach mal ein fight komplett ohne
rüstung her ich bin nackt darf mich an
ja macht traf mich an ich hab keine
rüstung er steht den früheren chef der
fall treffen kann ich ihn einsammeln
ich weiß nicht was kommt er kommt er
kommt aber zwar zwei hits guck mal wie
schnell ich weg bin
plextor menowins okay die mittel ist da
vorne
das parkieren die runde sie die und ihr
habt die runde gewonnen zwar durch zeit
und licht durch kills aber okay leute
ich muss mich jetzt erst mal stundenlang
mit dem material beschäftigen um da
irgendwas cooles eben zu basteln
das war's wald von mir unbedingt
reinschreiben wieso das mit den superjet
es hat nicht funktioniert hat dann sehen
wir für die nächsten folge wieder biss
dann macht's gut